but a breaking news we can bring you
from coventry crown court a mother who
was addicted to drugs has been sentenced
to 20 years for the gross negligence and
manslaughter of her seven-year-old son
this was hakeem hussain he suffered from
severe asthma laura heath smoked heroin
and was asleep when her son woke up and
had a fatal asthma attack he was found
dead in the garden of her home in
birmingham back in 2017 she's been
sentenced to 20 years
in prison let's talk to becky johnson
who is up there in coventry clan calls
for us becky this is a desperately sad
story isn't it it sounds like an
incredibly chaotic lifestyle and this
little boy caught in the middle of it
and just left to die
it's an extremely distressing case
seven-year-old hakeem hussain suffered
from very serious asthma but asthma this
court
was told that could and should have been
managed by his mother instead though she
prioritized her abuse of heroin and
cocaine above all else above the health
and then indeed the life of her son
sentencing her just now the judge told
her hakeem died as a result of your
deplorable negligence your catastrophic
and deplorable parenting his death was
needless tragic and a result of your
abject failure as his mother laura he'd
sat in the dock and she dabbed her eyes
as the judge talked about her
seven-year-old son describing him as a
child who'd been bubbly and full of life
but he died on his own in the night in
the garden of a flat of a friend of his
mother's where they'd been staying
clutching a leaf in his hand having
suffered a severe asthma attack but he
couldn't wake his mother because she was
asleep high on drugs he died alone the
judge said it would have been terrifying
for him when laura heath was found
guilty of manslaughter we did hear from
the chief executive of birmingham
children's trust he said social workers
missed clear opportunities to prevent
hakeem's death this trial heard that it
wasn't just hakeem's mother who was
aware of his ill health there were
several professionals involved in his
case indeed there had been a child
protection conference just in the days
before he died in november 2017 at that
meeting a school nurse had told the
meeting that she feared that hakeem
could die at the weekend a decision was
made at that meeting that hakeem's
mother would be spoken to by a social
worker on the monday hakim in fact
passed away in the early hours of this
sunday morning we also heard that at
that meeting a family outreach worker
from the school had voted that hakeem
should be taken immediately into care
this is a desperately sad story there is
a serious case review being carried out
about the contact that hakeem had with
multiple authorities this was a
preventable death the judge said when
jailing hakeem's mother to 20 years in
prison